now U.S President Joe Biden has welcomed
the results of the midterm elections
after his party fared better than
expected U.S media had predicted huge
gains for Republicans but these failed
to materialize however Biden's Democrats
do look set to lose control of the House
of Representatives the battle for the
upper chamber the Senate is also on a
knife edge with three Estates still left
to declare
there was a spring in this step of the
U.S president as he faced reporters at
the White House the waiter pre-election
fears perhaps lifted from his shoulders
after better than expected midterm
results
it was a good day I think for democracy
and I think it was a good day for
America excuse me a little horse
our democracy has been tested in recent
years but uh with their votes uh the
American people have spoken and proven
once again that democracy is who we are
this was a big test for Joe Biden who
couldn't hide his Glee when
congratulating Democrats who'd helped
see off a predicted Republican
surgeons congratulations Joe Biden
congratulations
I'm better knowing you won I tell you
hey congratulations I'm so happy for you
I really am the Democrats may have done
better than even the president expected
but without still being counted there is
still much to play for what happens here
in Nevada could be pivotal to who wins
control of the Senate it's one of three
states that could swing the U.S up a
house back into Republican hands
patience now the watchword here with
hundreds of Staff working to process
ballots
I know there is Georgia where the race
between Democratic incumbent Raphael
Warnock and Republican Challenger
Herschel Walker will now go into a
runoff in December
at the end of the day everyone wants to
know that we have honest and fair
elections and we do
I'll ask the voters to come out and vote
one last time
just a few days ago former president
Donald Trump's mood had been buoyant as
he celebrated initial Republican
successes he hand-picked many of the
names on the ballot in key States but in
true Trump style he's now described the
vote as somewhat disappointing in a
message to supporters on his own social
platform whilst also hailing a very big
victory
and we can get more from our Washington
correspondent
Michaela Joe Biden clearly pleased with
the outcome was it really a good day for
the Democrats though
well overall it wasn't but it wasn't as
bad as expected I guess success always
is what you get against the initial
expectation and there was lots of talk
about a red wave well that simply didn't
materialize the Republicans fancied
themselves as expecting a red tsunami
um so in Joe Biden's Democrats held up
much better than all the pollsters
predicted and then that many of
themselves actually believed and this is
against the backdrop of an almost
political tradition that the party of
whoever is a president usually doesn't
do particularly well in midterm
elections there was a very high turnout
that usually favors the Democrats so
this is a highly politicized country
certainly by midterm term terms and Joe
Biden his party I I would like to stress
pulled this off against the backdrop of
a fairly no approval ratings of their
president and three quarters of the
country saying that the U.S isn't going
in the right direction so figure that
overall the Democrats held up a sweeping
success looks different and Trump failed
to meet all expectations
which brings me nicely on to the next
question where do the midterms leave the
Republicans now and what about Trump I
mean is the Republican party starting to
question his leadership
the short answer is yes clearly the
gloves are off we're seeing Mike Pence
the former vice president now come up
publicly with statements talking about
his last days in office talking about
the president after he told him that he
didn't have the power to overturn votes
the president basically telling him to
do so this is very interesting because
Mike Pence too had followed the rhetoric
of doubting elections doubting the
results throughout this campaign and it
appears that the gloves are off the
Republicans are launching something that
one could at this moment describe as
soul-searching where they went wrong
Donald Trump backed candidates didn't do
as well as expected and the big new
shining star is Rhonda santis who is
really with a surprisingly large margin
one in Florida he's managed to capture
the all-important Latino voter group and
he himself is speaking of a new
political era so it's very interesting
timing that Trump still looks set on
declaring this coming Tuesday that he
wants to run again as president but a
lot can happen in a few hours in U.S
politics
reporting from Washington D.C thanks so
much for that
for more joining me now on the studio is
Tyson Barker senior fellow at the German
Council on Foreign Relations here in
Berlin welcome Tyson now we've just
heard Joe Biden there sounding pretty
pleased with the outcome but what does
this actually mean for the for the
Democrats what will they be able to get
done in the next two years well I think
it's going to be very dependent on what
happens with the Senate um generally
obviously we are looking at a situation
where the Senate could go either way
still but what we see in this result is
the country remains still very divided
even if the Republicans win control of
the house which looks likely it's going
to be just within a couple of seats and
that's going to leave the house quite
dysfunctional because uh the leader
Kevin McCarthy a weak leader will have
to Corral coordinate different very
fractious uh fractions of the party the
Maga group the um the freedom caucus Etc
and then there's going to be this Trump
pressure so it's not looking like the
legislative agenda will be the place
where policy moves forward it's going to
be executive action the mega group just
to make clear is the Trump the trumpists
right they make America great again
that's it let's talk a little bit more
about the Republicans so where do the
midterms really leave them and what
about Donald Trump well if you look at
the the candidates including Brad
raffensberger who was just speaking uh
the secretary of state of Georgia who
won his re-election decisively and was
of course the center of a lot of
pressure from Trump to uh to uh look for
votes in the 2020 election a lot of the
candidates the Republican candidates who
are able to emancipate themselves from
Trump actually much over performed
outperformed do you see this in Ohio you
see it in Georgia with the governor in
Georgia as well you see it in Florida so
there's going to be a lot of Elite
pressure in Republican circles including
conservatives Fox News Etc to try to
bring up new power centers within the
party you touched on it a little bit
earlier what effect are these midterms
like to have on the political dynamic in
in Washington I mean will the
Republicans given that it wasn't the red
tsunami that was potentially expected
will the Republicans offer some level of
cooperation do you think well in
contrast to 2010 where there was the
last major Republican shellacking uh in
a congressional election and they took
control of the house uh with the Tea
Party they actually had a an agenda
which was austerity to cut physical
responsibility Etc and they didn't
really run on that this time what we can
expect is a lot of very aggressive
oversight the debt ceiling which is a
traditional Congressional uh
responsibility to raise the ability to
borrow the full faith and credit of the
United States is going to come a
brinksmanship issue early next year and
there's going to be a lot of oversight
hearings we can of course assume right
off the top of the back of the January 6
committee the investigative committee
will be shuttered that's going to be one
of the first things that they do and
they're going to start equally the
aggressive investigations into for
example Hunter Biden's connections to
Ukraine to barisma and to China okay so
we're not looking smooth sailing ahead
it's going to be a contentious
Washington I think Tyson Barker thanks
so much for your time thank you